get comfortable
turn inward
hone in on the very ecstasy
that the breath brings
recognize that
the thoughts that are appearing
are like clouds
that appear in the sky of your awareness
become the sky
not the body
you are not a finite creature
you are source
you are infinity
expressing itself
know yourself as that
which eternally expresses itself
know this reality
as a dreamed expression
of that infinitude
know that you are a unique
expression of that source
you are a unique firework
you have a unique contributory gift
to bring this civilization
and to both realize yourself
as infinity as source
into fully maximally
actualize your unique contributory
firework is the nature
of who we are
you are not the body
you are not the finite biological
creature
you are the eternal shared awareness
where all thoughts experiences
sensations perceptions beliefs
feelings emotions arise
and then fall like clouds
in the sky
silence is the key
silence creates subtlety
subtlety creates the ability to go
beyond the body to the eternal shared
awareness the subtlety is what
enables one to truly pierce
the veilless veil to recognize
themselves
as the sky
and more and more
they keep their head above the clouds
you recognize yourself more and more as
the sky
you identify yourself as awareness
and not as the thought
the emotion that is transient that is
for those that are not jedi
those thoughts and emotions will take
them on
the
bathing in ego
hatred anger jealousy greed
fear the greatest
illusions of all
those are not you you are not that
the nature of your awareness is
peace it is happiness
it is satchit ananda it is that very
truth consciousness bliss
we bring
peace and happiness to
the dreamed creation design we do not
try to extract
peace and happiness from maya
from the illusion from the
intoxication from what is transient
we bring peace and happiness to our
relationships
we bring peace and happiness
to all of our activities
we bring child like awe and play
again recognize the breath
recognize the very inhalations and
exhalations
that happened 20 000 times per day
this very planet and this very star
absolutely sustain you
the photosynthesis of the phytoplankton
and the trees
are what enable the planetary
oxygenation
that you then inhale
and you feed them with your co2 in the
exhalations
to recognize that level of oneness
even at the level
of the appearance of form
the appearance of physicalism of matter
which is ultimately no thing quantum
mechanically
modulating energetically and appearing
as
form as matter as physicalism
but to recognize the very oneness of
that dreamed creation design where you
cannot even be the observer or the
witness
in that dreamed creation design
without the very environment of the
planet and the star that sustain you
that is the level of oneness
consciousness and matter are not two
they are one
in your dream at night
when you're sleeping you simulate out a
reality
you need an observer
to experience that simulated environment
similarly you need an environment for
the simulated observer to experience
the dream is not to the dream
is one this reality
is one
there are many other examples
we are still drinking the same water
that dinosaurs drank
66 million years ago it's the same
planetary hydrological cycle
you have over 1 000 species of bacteria
in your gut microbiome each of them has
2 000 gene expressions
2 million total gene expressions
meanwhile a human 20 000
gene expressions 100x more gene
expressions
just in the bacteria in your gut that
are billions of years old that have
evolved over billions of years to have
intelligence that are now in a symbiotic
union with
you
where is the line of separation
it does not exist there is no line of
separation between you
and the gut bacteria there's no line of
separation between you
and the oxygen that you inhale in the
co2 that you
exhale there is no line of separation
between you
and the water that you drink and then
urinate out there is no
line of separation none
to recognize that is to liberate oneself
from being
a separate entity
when you liberate yourself from being
that separate entity you no longer
become
just a contracted energy and a body you
recognize that you are
one with everything that is a
paramount first step toward
enlightenment
so recognition of oneness
is a paramount first step away from the
contracted
energy of being a finite biological
creature
now beyond that oneness is
an even more subtle recognition
which is recognizing yourself as the
seer
recognizing yourself as awareness
the recognition of awareness is the
recognition of the sky
the very sky where all of the clouds of
experience
appear
so just like in that dream that you're
simulating at night
you recognize yourself as the very
observer
you recognize that all of us
are those very witnesses
that we share that awareness
most commonly able to be visualized
childlike through the pupil
the pupil is that shared awareness it is
the seer it is god
we are that
and the iris around the pupil is the
unique
coloration of that expression of source
of infinity
that is why you are your unique firework
in the stream i am my unique firework in
the stream
in the ultimate we are the same source
the same infinitude
expressing itself as these unique
fireworks
so the levels of subtlety keep
increasing
as you go on the inward journey in these
meditations
and as you reach
home metaphysical zero
beyond everything beyond nothing
the very attributeless and agentless
absolute
you recognize your own true nature
the very diamond that has been around
your neck
that you have not been subtle enough to
recognize yet
once that is recognized flawlessly
we express ourselves outward into the
dreamed creation design
as an agent of that
absolute only expressing itself from the
absolute highest morality
no less only the greatest
ethics only the greatest maximization of
prosperity
and abundance and well-being and bliss
for all
become more sensitive become more subtle
use the breath as the tool it's been
taught for millennia
recognize yourself as the sky
that shared eternal awareness
recognize yourself as the infinitude
as the very source of even that
awareness itself
thank you